[音楽]
9号
僧僧してみてください
授業がない
先生もいない
通知表もない学校に皆さんは生徒として入学しました
そしてそこにいるスタッフに語を言われます
次に過ごしていいよっ
さあみなさんはどんな風に過ごしますか
楽しそうと思われる方
ありがとうございます象言われてもどうやって過ごしたらいいの思われる方
ありがとうございます
はいいろいろあると思います
私はこのような学校約8年前に作りました
この学校では長い時間本を読む子
何人かでゲームを囲んで大騒ぎをする子がいます
料理をする子
外で鬼ごっこで走り回ると思います
落ち葉に埋もれルコ思います
みんなもっといろんなたくさんのことをしています
お昼ご飯を食べるのもいつ食べてもいいです
時間を前に家決めて食べると思います
朝一番に広げてロリっと食べてしまう子もいますし
食べるのを忘れていつのまにか帰る時間になってしまうと思います
ここでは自分で自分のことをすべて決めているのです
この様子を見てずっと放課後みたい
どうぞ
人もいます
一時ば
女の子4人がダンスグループをつくって
校内でライブを何度も主催していました
彼女たちは
学校の一つの部屋を自分達専用に何ヶ月も借り切ってダンスの練習やステージ当日まで
の打ち合わせや準備をしていました
ライブ本番はとても盛り上がりを撮る人も見る人も汗だくになるほどでした
こんなアクティブなこともあればごろーんと
寝ている人もいます
今
を言ってスタッフをバンバン叩いてくる人もいます
生徒たちは言います
自由は
自分で何でも決めなきゃいけない
自分にのしかかってくるものが大きいたっ
誰かに指示をされるのであればその人の言うことを聞けばいいんです
でも自由になったとたん
自分で何事も考え
その結果をすべて受け負わなければなりません
さて a
誰かの事由が優先されると他の人の不自由を生み出すこともあります
例えば今は寒いですよね一つのこたつの中に
を人も
う美の所まですっぽりこたつの中に入っている子がいたとします
もう5人目の子は足を入れる隙間もないかもしれません
のようなときはそこにいる人たちでみんなが満足できるように調整をする必要があり
ます
当事者同士の話し合いです
俺がこの学校でのもう一つの大きな特徴です
生徒とスタッフ全員に参加資格のある
ミーティングというのがあります
ここでは
スクールの日常のことはもちろん
ゲイ面に関することも含めてすべてのことを話し合って決めていきます
例えば
お金を何に使うのか入学希望者を受け入れるのか
さらにはどんなルールを機作るのか
そして
スタッフの採用までそこで話し合われます
これがミーティングの様子です
今年のスタッフ募集も生徒が主体になって話し合いを進めていました
こんな感じで話を進めていました
投票率をアップさせたい
あったらもっと書きやすい投票用紙にしないとネー
新しいスタッフにはいくらのお給料がいいだろう
大人たちはいくらだったら魅力的に感じるのかな
などと話し合いをしていました
ミーティングで決められたことはこの学校では絶対です
ミーティングで決めたルールは守らなければ訴えられます
もし納得できないルールがあれば自分から行動して変えていかなければなりません
例えば昔こんなルールがありました
年齢制限のあるものは
学校の中に持ち込まないというものです
強い映像は見たくない
でも誰かがもし見てたらそれを目にしちゃうかもしれないからルールにしたいという
生徒の声と年齢の低い人には見てほしくないものもあるという保護者の声をもとに
ミーティングで話し合って決めたものでした
ところが何年か経ちこのルールを不便に感じる12歳の子が出てきました
日頃はミーティングにあまり参加しない子でしたが
その時その子がとても夢中になっていたゲームを家だけでなく学校でももっとやりたい
でもこのルールがあるからできない何とかしたい
ということでした
ダンボールで小さな小部屋を作りその中でなら見てもいいというのはどうかなという
アイデアのもと
彼女は
大きな段ボールを組み立てて部屋の中に
また小さな部屋を
作ろうと作業を始めました
心がこの作業は関西には至りませんでした
彼女はどうやら途中で続けるのが面倒になってしまったそうです
それから何日か経っていっ
しばらくして彼女は
思い切ったようにミーティングで議題を提案しました
これまでのルールを次のように変えたいということでした
年齢制限のあるものは決められた部屋でのみ使うことはできる
そのときは部屋の出入り口に年齢制限のあるものを使っていると書いた看板を出す音は
出さないというものでした
これなら怖いものを見たくない子は韓方を見れば入ってこなくて済むし
音が聞きたくないこのためにイヤホンを使っていればいいよねという考えでした
彼女はこう言いました
周りの子達が納得できるようにそして自分が満足できる形にルールを変えたかったと
ようやくできた
そう言っていました
彼女がルールを変えたいと思ってから
いまの形になるまで
約2年かかりました
1日でできてしまうルールもあればこうして長い時間かけて
できるルールもあります
このような話し合いの場を返さなくても
子どもたちは自由な環境の中で
自分たちでマーリと調整をするようになることもあります
4歳で入学してきたある子は初めの頃
ルールをあまり守れず片付けもなかなかしてくれませんでした
ルール違反だよって言うと見えないところに隠れてしまい周りの人を困らせました
他の子たちとケンカをすることもよくありました
ルール違反が重なってついにはルールを守ろうと思うようになるまでは
学校に来て欲しくないんでミーティングで言われたこともありました
何年か経って
彼女はいつからかルールをとても気をつけるようになったのです
困っている子を気遣って声をかけるようにもなりました
彼女に一体何が起きたのでしょうか
本人に聞いてみると
なんでかわかんないけどもしかしたら
難しいと州へのことの間で思うようにいかなかったことがあって
持っても悔しくって
その時に
自分のしたことで他の子にイヤな思いをさせる場合もあるのかも
って思ったのかもしれない
と言っていました
私はどうかといったら
私が子供の頃は
周りの大人の評価を気にしていい子でいるように良い点数を取るようにと思いながら
過ごしていました
を考え方は私の中で浸透し
そのまま大人になりました
就職して働く場所が変わるといいと言われることが大きく変わってとても戸惑ったこと
があったのです
何が本当はいいことなの思いました
そこでようやく気がつきました
周りがどう思うかを優先して自分の考えを後回しにしてきたことで
私がどう考えるのか私自身がどんな人なのかがわからなくなってしまっていたことに
そして本当に大事なのは
私が何を感じ
自分自身が何を感じ
そしてどうしたいのか
そこに耳を澄ませることだったんだとようやくわかったんです
この学校は子どもたちが自分の思いを大切にして自分の自由とまぁりとの調整を常に
日々の繰り返しの中でしています
10年後20年後彼らが社会に出た時に
この日々の繰り返しにより得た学びがこれからの多様性のある社会においても自分
らしく
満足して生きていける力になる
そう信じています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]